HER OFFICE DID NOT RESPOND TO
FOX NEWS’S REQUEST FOR COMMENT.
JILLIAN: LET’S BRING IN THE
HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE MEMBER
LEADING THE LETTER.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I KNOW YOU HAD THAT RALLY
YESTERDAY AND YOU’VE BEEN
OUTSPOKEN ABOUT THIS FOR ALMOST
A YEAR NOW.
YOU HAVE BEEN PASSIONATE ABOUT
IT, YOU WANT ANSWERS AS DO MANY
OTHERS.
DO YOU FINALLY FEEL YOUR VOICES
BEING HEARD?
>> I DO.
IT HAS TAKEN 10 MONTHS BUT
BETTER LATE THAN NEVER.
YESTERDAY WAS A GOOD DAY.
THERE WAS A LOT OF PRESS AT THAT
EVENT.
I CREDIT RON KIM FOR BRING
BRINGING THE PRESS.
FOX NEWS HAS BEEN COVERING THIS,
THE NEW YORK POST.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME JOURNALIST
IN ALBANY, NEW YORK BUT THIS HAS
BEEN RELATIVELY UNCOVERED AND
THE GOVERNOR HAS BEEN REVERED
FOR THE LAST YEAR.
TODD: WILL THIS REQUEST YOU HAVE
FOR SUBPOENAS OF GOVERNOR CUOMO
BE GRANTED?
>> WHO KNOWS?
MALONEY HAS NOT BEEN GOOD AT
GRANTING OUR REQUESTS BUT THIS
IS THE JOB OF THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE BUT NANCY PELOSI
CREATED A CORONAVIRUS.
MISMANAGEMENT, WASTE, FRAUD AND
ABUSE.
I’M SURE SHE WAS HOPING THAT
WOULD INVOLVE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BUT WITH THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FINDING THE
MOST CONCERNING MISMANAGEMENT
AND FORM OF ABUSE IS AT THE
HANDS OF GOVERNOR CUOMO WITH THE
NURSING HOME POLICY.
WE WANT ANSWERS IN THE VICTIMS
WANT ANSWERS.
JILLIAN: YOU HEAR CONGRESSMAN
COMEARE, HOW MUCH DOES THIS HELP
YOUR EFFORT TO HAVE HIM AND
OTHER SUPPORTING YOU AND TRYING
TO GET THESE ANSWERS, TRYING TO
GET THEM UNDER OATH AS BEST YOU
CAN?
>> ANYONE TRYING TO SPREAD THE
MESSAGE AND HELP OUR FAMILIES IS
ANOTHER WIN FOR US.
IT HAS TO RESONATE AT HOME.
PEOPLE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
STORY.
IT’S NOT HARD TO UNDERSTAND IT.
WE HAD ELDERLY INFECTED BY THE
VIRUS BECAUSE OUR GOVERNOR AT
9000 NURSING PATIENTS IN A
NURSING HOME, NOT HARD TO
UNDERSTAND AT ALL.
TODD: IT ISN’T ROCKET SCIENCE,
WE WERE TOLD TO STAY HOME, THEY
DID EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE.
HOW DOES THIS SAD SAGA END?
>> THE SELECT COMMITTEE WILL NOT
LET UP ON THIS.
STEVE SCALISE AND JIM JORDAN HAD
PRIMARILY BEEN HIGHLIGHTING
THIS, MESSAGING THIS AND
REPRESENT NOT JUST THE FAMILIES
OF THE VICTIMS BUT THE TAXPAYERS
AND THE PEOPLE OF NEW YORK, WE
ARE NOT GOING TO LET UP ON IT.
MALONEY WILL CAVE UNDER
PRESSURE.
SHE REPRESENTS NEW YORK AND THE
NEW YORK LEGISLATORS, DEMOCRAT
AND REPUBLICAN INCLUDING OCASIO
CORTEZ CALLED ON THE COMMITTEE
TO SUBPOENA CUOMO, I THINK CUOMO
HAS A LOT OF QUESTIONS TO ANSWER
IN THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
AND COVID-19 SELECT COMMITTEE
WON’T LET UP ON THIS.
JILLIAN: WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
PEOPLE WHO DON’T SUPPORT THIS
LETTER DEMANDING THE SUBPOENA?
>> Reporter: THIS IS NOT ABOUT
POLITICS.
IT NEVER HAS BEEN.
IT IS NOT ABOUT REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRAT.
IT IS ABOUT WHAT IS RIGHT AND
WHAT IS WRONG AND TO ENSURE THAT
THIS KIND OF THING NEVER HAPPENS
TO ANOTHER FAMILY AGAIN.
PEOPLE NEED TO SUPPORT THIS.
TODD: SAME QUESTION I ASKED THE
CONGRESSMAN.
HOW DOES THE SAD SAGA ULTIMATELY
END?
>> WE DON’T HAVE OUR LOVED ONES
BACK.
>> WE WILL CONTINUE PRESSING ON
THIS AND DEMOCRATS ARE GOOD AT
EVENTUALLY READING PUBLIC
OPINION.
PUBLIC OPINION IN NEW YORK IS
PEOPLE WANT ANSWERS AND WE NEED
TO LEARN FROM HISTORY.
IT IS NOT ABOUT POLITICS, THIS
IS ABOUT FINDING ANSWERS, IT IS
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY AND MAKING
SURE SOMETHING LIKE THIS NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN.
>> JANICE: I WISH I COULD HAVE
MY RELATIVES BACK BUT IF I CAN
LEND MY VOICE TO THOSE WHO DON’T
HAVE ONE I WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT EVEN WHEN THIS ISN’T A
NEWS STORY ANYMORE.
I WILL.
>> BEHIND-THE-SCENES YOU HAVE
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH SO MANY
FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN ON THIS
PROGRAM, YOU REACHED OUT TO ME A
WEEK AGO SAYING TRIED TO FIND
THEIR CONTACT INFORMATION TO
REACH OUT TO THEM, PEOPLE WE HAD
ON THE SHOW AND IT HAS BEEN